wisdom is one of the grandest and oddest
words out there so lofty doesn't sound
like something one could ever
consciously strive to be unlike say
being healthy or kind nevertheless
though it's impossible ever to reach a
stable state of wisdom as an aspiration
wisdom deserves to be rehabilitated and
take its place among a host of other
more typical goals one might Harbor
wisdom seems woven from many strands the
wise are first and foremost realistic
about how challenging many things can be
they aren't devoid of hope that would be
a folly of its own but their conscious
of the complexities entailed in any
project for example raising a child
starting a business spending an
agreeable weekend with a family falling
in love knowing that something difficult
is being attempted doesn't Rob the whys
of ambitions but it makes them more
steadfast karma and less prone to panic
about the problems that will invariably
come their way
properly aware that much can and does go
wrong the wiser unusually alive two
moments of calm and beauty even
extremely modest ones they can take
pleasure in a single uneventful sunny
day or some pretty flowers growing by a
brick wall it isn't that they're
sentimental and naive precisely the
opposite because they've seen how hard
things can be to get they know how to
draw the full value from the peaceful
and the sweet whenever and wherever
these arise the wise know that all human
beings themselves included are deeply
sunk in folly we all have irrational
desires and wanting compatible things
we're prone to mood swings and buffeted
by the curious demands of our sexuality
the wise our unsurprised by the ongoing
coexistence of deep immaturity and
sexual perversity alongside quite adult
qualities like intelligence and morality
they know that we are barely evolved
Apes aware that at least half of life is
irrational they try wherever possible to
budget for madness and a slow to panic
when it reliably rears its head the wise
take the business of laughing at
themselves seriously they laugh about
the constant collisions between the
noble way they'd like things to be and
the demented way they in fact of
turn out the wise are realistic about
social relations in particular about how
difficult it is to change people's minds
and have an effect on their lives they
are therefore extremely reticent about
telling people too frankly what they
think they have a sense of how seldom
it's useful to get censorious with
others they want above all that things
go well between people even if this
means not being totally honest so
they'll sit with someone of an opposite
political persuasion and not try to
convert them they'll hold their tongue
at someone who seems to be announcing a
wrongheaded plan for reforming the
country educating their child or
directing their personal life they'll be
aware of how differently things can look
through the eyes of others and will
search more for what people have in
common than what separates them the wise
have made their peace with the yawning
gap between how they would ideally want
to be and what they're actually like
they've come to terms with their idiocy
x' floors ugliness limitations and
drawbacks they're not ashamed of
themselves and yet they understand their
craziness they can give those close to
them a fairly accurate map of the
reasons where they're pretty hard to
live with the Y's are realistic about
other people too they recognize the
extraordinary pressures everyone is
under to pursue their own ambitions
defend their interests and seek their
own pleasures it can make other people
appear extremely mean and purposefully
evil but this would be to / personalize
the issue the Y's know that most hurt is
not intentional it's a by product of the
constant collision of blind competing
egos in a world of scarce resources the
Y's are therefore slow to anger and
judge they don't leap to the worst
conclusions about what's going on in the
minds of others they will be ready to
forgive from a proper sense of how
difficult every life is harboring as it
does so many frustrated ambitions
disappointments and longings the Y's
appreciate the pressures people are
under of course they shouted of course
they were rude naturally they want to
overtake on the inside lane the Y's are
generous to the reasons for which people
might not be quite so nice they feel
less persecuted by the aggression and
meanness of others
because they have a sense of where it
comes from a place of hurt the Y's have
a solid sense of what they can survive
they know just how much can go wrong and
things will still be just about liveable
the unwise person draws the boundaries
of their contentment far too far out so
that it accompanies and depends upon
fame money personal relationships
popularity health the wise person sees
the advantages of all of these but also
knows that they may before too long at a
time of fates choosing have to draw the
borders right back and find contentment
with in a much more bounded space the
wise person doesn't envy idly they
realize that there are some good reasons
why they don't have many of the things
they really want they look at the tycoon
or the film star and have a decent grasp
of why they didn't ever make it to that
level it looks like just an accident and
unfair one but there were in facts and
logical grounds they didn't work as hard
they didn't have anything like the drive
or mental capacity or looks at the same
time the wise see that some destinies
are truly shaped by nothing more than
accident some people are promoted
randomly companies that aren't
especially deserving can suddenly make
it big some people have the right
parents
the winners aren't all Noble and good
the wise appreciate the role of luck and
don't curse themselves overly at those
junctures where they've evidently not
had as much of it as they would have
liked in our ambitious era it's common
to begin with dreams of being able to
pull off an unblemished life where one
can hope to get the major decisions in
love and work right but the wise realize
that it's impossible to fashion a
spotless life one will make some
extremely large and utterly
uncorrectable errors in a number of
areas perfectionism is a wicked illusion
regret is unavoidable but regret lessens
the more we see that error is endemic
across the species one can't look at
anyone's life story without seeing some
devastating mistakes edged across it
these errors are not coincidental but
structural they arise because we all
lack the information we need
to make choices in time-sensitive
situations we are all where it counts
steering almost blind the wise know that
turmoil is always just around the corner
and they've come to fear and sense its
approach that's why they nurture such a
strong commitment to the idea of being
calm a quiet evening feels like an
achievement a day without anxiety is
something to be celebrated the wise are
not afraid of having a somewhat boring
time there could and will again be so
much worse
you